là on est effectivement parti à madrid
pour je suis remis mais je vous ai pas
montrer ma chambre d'hôtel qui en fin de
compte n'est pas une chambre mais plutôt
une magnifique suite qui coûte tout
simplement la petite bagatelle de crise
[Musique]
aujourd'hui départ de madrid
voilà moi aussi si vous avez suivi mes
autres épisodes on était à madrid dans
un hôtel de ouf le westin qui est qui et
qui est qui et qui est là voilà hôtel
énorme palace 5 étoiles en plein coeur
de madrid à côté du musée du prado un
truc qui déchire on va regarder un petit
peu ce qui a pu surtout je vous garde le
meilleur pour la fin
vous allez voir la bicis et bars pour
jack le même silence c'est la classe là
c'est la galerie des glaces côté plus
boulot pour schumi
ces classes grand galerie des glaces
c'est très très très très grand même la
salle de restaurant énorme
vous avez un dôme ces patients franc
bien contenait un homme qui complètement
et d'un côté bouffe c'est plutôt pas mal
on mange bien bon dans un cinq étoiles
normalement vous avez un chef qui se
débrouille pas trop mal
ce soir c'est un dîner qui va déchirer
demain matin petit déj
on est pas mal aussi donc je voulais
partager un truc avec vous aujourd'hui
je me suis dit quitte à faire un voyage
de presse franchement cool et puis qui
fera voir un hôtel qui déchire et ben
autant et vous montrer la meilleure
pioche de l'hôtel nos fesses je vais
partager un voleur aujourd'hui de patek
c'est un petit peu différent pas de
technologie on va juste juste aller vous
montrer la chambre la plus cool
la plus belle la plus classieuses de
l'hôtel et puis on reparle de teck des
deux mondes
[Musique]
ici vous avez le premier petit salon
cosy si fort sympathique
[Musique]
la salle à manger le deuxième petit
salon avec de la lecture bien sûr de
quoi faire du feu l'hiver ici la cuisine
parce que forcément même quand on n'est
pas l'hôtel on peut vouloir se faire une
petite tablette là lui comme ferment
noblette je lave gma bouilloire madelon
dit j'ai un petit blind heures à micro
ondes
bien sûr le frigo américain avec tout le
nécessaire pour boire ça c'est cool un
petit coin toilette ici forcément fait
marbre très joli petit bla carrossier et
de ce côté là je suis complètement
perdue en fait l'un ah ça y est enfin
une salle de bains commence à parler
sérieusement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
petite salle de bain avec grande
baignoire ici forcément savoir si on a
pris un petit peu du poids en mangeant
des tapas la grande vasque ici ici
qu'est ce qu'on a des toilettes et
petite idée c'est juste énorme
je me perds là et là qu'est ce que j'ai
ici ah ouais aux cabines de douche ultra
g vous régler la température du nouveau
ce soir c'est juste complètement dingue
bien évidemment les peignoirs mais ça
c'est quand même un grand classique ici
ah voila voila on commence à parler
sérieusement on a
[Musique]
la chambre avec son petit coin salon ici
de quoi poser vos affaires de quoi
bosser et la magnifique lié baldaquin
avec je suppose la tv intégré ici et
tout ça pour la modique somme de 15
euros par jour
je crois que je suis un peu perdu assez
calme en ce triste big easy swiss krause
six feet under bébé forcément passagers
mais ce but je vais vous montrer ce
total je perds tous là on est quand même
plutôt pas mal
si vous avez suivi mes vidéos
précédentes on a parlé beaucoup de
schumi pendant ces deux jours hop et la
caméra qui se casse la gueule on a parlé
beaucoup de tirs au but pendant ces deux
jours on a parlé du nouveau smartphone
le mit à 2 on a parlé aussi dure et demi
si ça on va reparler de ces recrutements
parce qu'ils y avoir un test mais
forcément je me devais de vous montrer
cette jolie suite alors nombreux je vais
vous décevoir forcément c'était pas la
mienne j'aurais bien aimé mais bon
budget oblige xiaomi m'a pas payé une
suite à 40000 euros la nuit
malheureusement peut-être un jour on
serait jamais et lorsque vous venez à
madrid fait quelques économies
et puis vous venez au westin et vous
allez voir pour 40000 euros une
bagatelle
vous allez de quoi vous amuser merci à
vous d'avoir suivi mes aventures pendant
ces quelques jours à madrid on a
effectivement découvert le nouveau chiot
mille milliers de et le mit à de light
qu'il faut pas oublier on en reparle
quelques jours parce que j'ai récupéré
un produit je vais tester
on va regarder la photo la vidéo surtout
un petit peu la promesse qui fait
marcher au mit sur ce produit sur du
milieu de gamme
on a aussi une brosse à dents a testé un
pour voir si six chiots migros bien les
dents oui ou non donc ça c'est aussi un
truc qui peut être hyper cool
et puis on parle de plan là plein plein
de choses à l'été continue on va voyager
d'ici quelques temps je vous emmener
avec moi en vacances on va continuer la
petite série de l'été à reprendre un peu
des sujets que j'ai pas le temps de
traiter cette année il ya plein de
choses qui vont arriver puis surtout
surtout ça c'est un truc de dingue
c'est la rentrée qui va arriver au mois
de septembre avec plein de nouveautés un
format améliorer revu corrigé et puis
après tout si quelques jours il ya
samsung qui va présenter son galaxy note
donc on va bien évident
or parler enfin il ya plein de trucs qui
arrive donc ça c'est super cool merci à
vous de toujours plus nombreux toujours
plus nombreux à rester sage
ici à madrid il fait un temps de fou le
soleil brille il fait beau il fait chaud
j'avais presque me faire bronzer mais
non il faut partir à l'ayraultport back
home rentrée un bisou merci ciao
[Musique]